Karen morning with foam courage the
radio show we're outside the studio with
filmmaker and author Vincent Roca of
kisses and caroms and then we have rebel
without a deal here and we have romijn
Johnson our guest host who's going to
help me answer or should not hang answer
some questions ask some questions we
want to find out first what inspired you
to write the book um the book was about
money I mean I was you know from the
get-go I like it said earlier on the
show or later on the show that I don't
know where you're watching this video
the movie was set up in such a way that
you raised your hand no no I'm sorry I'm
sorry keep going he goes traction now
this is getting cat the movie was set up
in such a way that we were going to
write a book make it behind the scenes
doc have a soundtrack have a movie where
we had all our bases covered so the
concept of the book came from that it
was inspired by robert rodriguez is
rebel without a crew hence the name
rebel without a deal and it's very much
along his same lines the end result of
the story is what happens when you don't
get the three picture deal with Columbia
Pictures like Robert Rodriguez did what
happens when you go direct to video and
that's what rebel without a deal covers
so I mean that was the inspiration
behind it is obviously just to make a
buck the end result is it's probably the
biggest asset any filmmaker could ever
have in their tool bag because rebel
without a deal details exact budgets how
much we spent to make the movie how much
the movie made the statements from
Warner Brothers where every dime went
near where every done came from and
that's something that has not been seen
on any in any other book on any shelf of
how much money you can possibly make
with your movie so let me ask a quick
question
basically what you saying this is almost
like a rebirth of the old Hollywood
studio system you know where now you
have independent people like yourself
and up-and-coming you know film
entrepreneurs and people making films
now I mean I guess going back to the
studios right I think when you're
referring to and yes you're right is
that today everybody is their own studio
or everybody can be their own studio so
if you were to go back and old Hollywood
and look at how the Metro golden Marin
and the Warner Brothers did it Warner
Brothers is actually a great example
just ruthless marketing and cutthroat
deals and even miramax Bob and Harvey
great book called down and dirty
pictures which you should buy after you
buy my book um but talks about how the
Hollywood System Works and you can you
can become your own studio and with your
own film or with the slate of films and
be successful with it today by following
that model because distribution is in a
filmmakers hands where a decade ago it
was not and it was you had to be a
Hollywood mogul to get it today
distribution is in everybody's hands now
you have a conversation with kevin smith
in the book how did you approach kevin
smith um i stalked him a little bit it's
actually detailed a book on how I met
Kevin and how I got him to give me a
quote for the movie and then sit down he
sat down for four hours with me and an
interview that became about 60 pages of
conversation in the book um basically I
just kind of stalked him but Kevin is an
easy person is talk at the time he had
his forum as bulletin board and I would
just kind of learn about him and what he
was doing I live in LA he lives in LA I
had owned a retail gameroom store and
one day I saw that he was looking for
blackjack table so I sent his webmaster
a message saying that I could
provide them with a custom blackjack
table and that resulted in the initial
connection between him and i so today
kevin is very prolific in podcasting so
you could find Kevin that way and really
I mean just like with anybody that
you're trying to make friends with
you're looking for common ground I mean
you walk into a party and you're making
friends with somebody or looking for
common ground that you can connect with
them on and that would be it whether
it's kevin smith or steven spielberg try
and find where they are and try and
figure out how to connect with ya
smodcast calm I believe he has several
podcast including jay mohr and jason
mewes and things like that um so what is
it about kevin smith that struck you
that's so great I mean what does he have
that why didn't you approach Robert
Rodriguez or or someone else what's that
well Kevin is attainable to his fans
he's always been very connected to his
fans through his bulletin board Robert
not so much in Roberts also in Texas if
I was in Texas near Austin I know Robert
has a ranch there and I know he's right
from what I hear he's pretty available
in the community I probably wouldn't
stop Robert but Kevin's Kevin's movie
clerks is a lot more like kisses and
caroms and like the type of movie that I
enjoy as opposed to Robert Rodriguez's
films like era el Mariachi which is not
you know it's shoot him up and I mean
they're good movies but it really wasn't
what I was after making and still known
and after making um you know Quintin
would have been another one that I would
have tried to approach he's here in LA
as well as that I'm here in LA but quit
and actually quitting today is a lot
more accessible to his fans he owns the
New Beverly he goes to a lot of
screenings there it he'll go to oddball
screenings at the Newark on so the human
centipede opening night when I played at
the new art Quinton was there so he is
an accessible guy you can meet him you
can connect with them so he'll I rocked
it and look at that dudes career on so
that's why kevin i just kind of
connected with kevin a little bit
you know we're both kind of chubby
slacker registered jockeys and so it
sort of work that way that suppose let
me ask you a quick question now after
you experiences with kisses and caroms
and all the things that happen with the
studio and and the district is
distributors I think you're making a
working on a new film right yeah so a
lot of those mistakes and things
obviously I'll hopefully have been
eliminated right um yeah one hopes that
they've that they're not going to make
all the stain mistakes the second time
around but just anybody I'll tell you it
was on their fourth or fifth or sixth
relationship that you continue to make
mistakes so I'm not an idiot thinking
that I won't make those mistakes but I
certainly i'm going to try not to i mean
i have a road back for success now and
hopefully that works out of the next
movement yeah would you have release the
book without Kevin Smith's you know
interview in here uh you know that's
hard to say because I met Kevin a long
time ago and got the interview with him
a long time ago and it sat on the shelf
waiting mostly because I was waiting for
financials and distributor statements
before the book was really ready to
release so for a long time I knew that
kevin was attached to the book and
Kevin's conversations with Kevin were
going to be in the book so i don't i
don't know if i would have yeah i mean i
probably still would have because you
know selling one copy versus selling 10
copies is still one copy and that's you
know if it helps one person that's
better than nothing and if you know it
makes me money then that's better than
nothing did you go with a traditional
publisher for the books know how did you
know the book is actually published
brown demand through amazon so i did
send it out to some publishers and ones
actually it was kevin's publisher titan
you can
um I had a conversation with him and it
was very can't was it him or focal press
any one of them was very candid to say
look you know who your market is you
know who this book is for if you give it
to a publisher they're going to print a
bunch of copies and you're never going
to see a dime here's candid to say that
the publishing world works exactly like
the indie film world does and he said
since you already know your market is
you already have Kevin attached if you
self-publish this you'll do much better
than you ever will with a publisher and
i believe it was right he made a lot of
sense and it was a big enough publisher
I mean he wasn't interested in
distributing the book but he took enough
of an interest to spend about an hour on
the phone with me and explaining me with
the publishing business that was like so
he enjoyed the book enough to invest
that time in me I'm grateful to I'm
probably more grateful if I remembered
his name which company was with vocal
type so so in other words we're back to
square one as far as self distribution
yeah absolutely it's just amazing I mean
I mean you talked about the film
industry and how they screw you in
you're saying how you know to get the
book out how the big publishing houses
will screw you and I get paid anything
so it's really it's really about self
distribution I mean you have to do
everything for yourself right yeah if
you want to make money you have to do
everything for yourself if you just I
mean if you just want to make movies you
make product you can see the least sell
it conceivably sell it not make a profit
which means your investors don't profit
it which means you're always looking for
investors so you're working one way or
another you're constantly either having
an unbound investors or hunt down money
or distributors so you might as well
just distribute it yourself if it's the
best way to put money back in your
pocket to put money back into your next
film and to put money back into your
investors pocket who would reinvest with
you in any in any situation um today we
not always obviously
but look at you know all the internet
successes and music that you know put up
a YouTube video and a Friday the Friday
girl and Justin be Justin Bieber these
people did it on their own and did it in
a world where there was a slew of
producers or studios or production
companies or publishers or whatever you
want to call them go we're line enough
to say no to Bieber into Friday what's
your name Rebecca into something I think
for any girl anyway I'm good with names
obviously uh so but they did it on their
own and they've been wildly successful
so that being said which piece of
product is more difficult to get out
there in the marketplace the book or the
film well the film was distributed
through warner brothers and i went
through i went to each distributor to
find a home for today i'm not sure that
that's what i would do I would probably
self distribute it and by self
distributing the book or self
distributing the movie I think today
neither one is more difficult it's
they're both pretty easy to do companies
like Amazon and iTunes have just in
YouTube have just made it really easy
for you to get your product into the
marketplace so I don't really the one is
hard so there's no excuses for some
still wanna do things like this we have
normal excuses the only thing that's in
your way like I said during the show was
you know having the confidence to do it
just getting off your ass and going out
there and doing it that's the hardest
part early on it's in a book when I have
a conversation with Kevin's mother in
law she says that making a feature film
are making a movie is the hardest thing
that anybody can do and I immediately
disagreed with her and I said I don't
think it's harder at all it's just a
matter of getting off your ass and doing
it and I still believe that today many
movies that you see may independent
movies that are done just on blood sweat
and tears open water Paranormal Activity
clerks are just somebody getting off
their ass and doing it it isn't like I
mean open water they got refinanced his
house and or in paranormal activity you
know he took 15 grin of his own money
and clerks is 27,000 of his own money
it's getting off your ass and doing it
not waiting around for somebody who just
come about and go I think you're a
genius here's a check I mean that it's
just not going to happen even Bill Gates
and Steve Jobs nobody was like running
around going oh here's a check on both
of those guys busted their asses to get
those computer companies launched busted
their asses and believed in something
that everybody else thought was crazy I
mean today you take it for granted but
the idea of a mouse pointer on the
screen was just some stupid crazy thing
that was never going to take cold nobody
was that were really going to be
interested in that well you know history
is dictated the two guys who believed
and it made it happen well that goes
back I think to the book smarts versus
the street smarts and and sort of the
college teaching that you need
permission to go ahead and do things
whereas if you've done things by your
own rules you don't need anyone's
permission is that I move that's more of
a statement than a question but um yeah
I think that's more of a statement but
know that I mean that's true and it's
what I was trying to say about teachers
in there and you're the asking
permission and following the rules
that's what teachers do they follow the
rules what you need to do is take that
education treat it as a tool in your
handbag and do something with it and
turn it into something on your own
whatever that case may be music book
whatever a movie or a mouse pointer and
change the world and that's educated or
not or college graduate or street smart
the people who change the world are the
people who believed in what they were
doing and had the confidence to do it
does kisses and caroms change the world
probably not but one day I got a letter
from a soldier in Afghanistan who was a
really nice letter that said hey your
new guy sent movies over to Afghanistan
just on a whim he said hey your movie
was lying around here and I really
enjoyed it and it really made a
difference if you know really made me
laughing and took the edge off so that
make a difference it might have I don't
know but those are the people who make a
change in the world or people who get
off their ass and do something
Oh